Mr Speaker I beg to move the motion
earlier this week I promised I would
deal with the soaring Energy prices
faced by families and businesses across
the UK and today I am delivering on that
promise
this government is moving immediately to
introduce a new energy price guarantee
that will give people certainty on
energy bills it will curb inflation and
boost growth
this guarantee which includes a
temporary suspension of green levees
means that from the 1st of October a
typical household will pay no more than
2 500 pounds per year for each of the
next two years while we get the energy
Market back on track
[Music]
[Applause]
save at
household a thousand pounds a year it
comes in addition to the 400 pounds
Energy bill support scheme this
guarantee supersedes the off-gem price
cap and has been agreed with energy
retailers
we will deliver this
but I I will make way in a few minutes
when I have made some progress Miss
[Applause]
we will deliver this by securing the
wholesale price for energy while putting
in place long-term measures to secure
future supplies at more affordable rates
we are supporting this country through
this winter and next and tackling the
root causes of high prices
for those using heating oil living in
park homes or those on heat networks we
will set up a fund so that all can prime
minister sorry about this can I just say
I don't want a running commentary from
here and giving me the advice I
certainly don't need it promise I don't
want to in trouble it's up to you to
give away when you feel it's appropriate
but just to let you know that it is now
being printed the WMS and I'm hoping
that we'll bring into the gym but for
everybody to say prime minister
well thank you thank you Mr Speaker
for those using heating oil living in
park homes or those on heat networks we
will set up a fund so that all UK
consumers can benefit from equivalent
support
[Applause]
at the current level or six and a half
million households and fuel poverty so
raising a car to two and a half thousand
pounds how many more millions of people
will end up in fuel poverty this year
well Mr Speaker we are taking action to
help people
reversal credit and we are also
supplying 400 pounds through the energy
bills support scheme
Mr Speaker I would like to make some
progress and then I will take more
interventions we will also support all
businesses Charities and public sector
organizations with their energy costs
this winter offering equivalent
guarantee for six months
after those six months we will provide
further support to vulnerable sectors
such as Hospitality including our local
pubs
my right honorable friend the business
secretary will work with business to
review where they should be targeted to
make sure those most in need get support
this review will be concluded within
three months giving businesses certainty
in the meantime companies with the
wherewithal need to be looking for ways
they can improve Energy Efficiency and
increase Direct Energy generation I will
give way to my old girlfriend I'm
grateful to the Prime Minister giving
way and I commend her on the speed with
which she and her new team
grip this challenge that's facing the
country and doesn't it demonstrate Mr
Speaker that conservative governments do
not stand by while millions of people on
low income
well my my honorable friend is
absolutely right I recognize that people
are struggling with their energy bills
and that is why I have brought forward
this debate as soon as possible to give
people reassurance ahead of this winter
that energy bills are going to be
affordable
and we will be bringing forward
emergency legislation to deliver this
policy my right honorable friend the
chancellor of the exchequer will set out
the expected costs as part of his fiscal
statement later this month and I can
tell the house today that we will not be
giving in to the leader of the
opposition who calls who calls for this
to be funded through a windfall tax that
would undermine the national interest by
discouraging the very investment we need
to secure the home grown energy supplies